you still know how to make an entrance
Batman is a troubled hero and past
Arkham games haven't shied away from
exploring his dark side Arkham Knight is
no exception in this open-world
adventure the Caped Crusader growls his
way through one confrontation after
another in which he must question his
role in Gotham's current crisis we've
seen this before the game covers so much
familiar thematic ground that you could
only say I know I know the many many
times you reminded the Batman's brand of
Justice puts those he loves in arms way
it's fortunate then that Arkham Knight
for all the areas it revisits features
the qualities developer Rocksteady has
infused its previous games with superb
production values hard-hitting combat
and a wonderful sense of freedom as you
soar above the skies of Gotham
there is one iconic object looming over
the Freedom however and that is the
Batmobile for the first time in this
series you can leap in
famous vehicle and zoom down the street
Gotham the driving itself is slick and
satisfying but there's no beating the
incredible rush of using your line
launcher to fling yourself through the
sky
not to mention that taking the air is
usually faster as a result Arkham Knight
is constantly trying to justify the
Batmobiles presence particularly in the
latter third of the story
you're constantly forced to get behind
the wheel and take part in tedious
vehicular battles against remotely man's
drones you first engage in this kind of
combat which turns the Batmobile into
the world's most agile tank it's a
delight but in spite of the upgrades you
earn over time
EMP blasts the ability to hack enemy
drones and so forth the Batmobile
battles never become more interesting
just more monotonous as they seem to go
on forever the Batmobile is also the
centerpiece of a number of mediocre boss
encounters in all manner of puzzles it's
forced upon you at every turn even in
the many challenges River provides you
so don't be surprised if you end up
muttering yourself too much Batmobile
Arkham Knight is at its best when you're
given the freedom you both need and
deserve what a treat it is to look down
upon this beautiful and derelict City
which has been deserted by most
citizenry due to Scarecrow's most recent
threat to release a hallucinogenic toxin
into the streets
Batman is beautifully animated and an
absolute joy to control to soar towards
man bat and tackle the shrieking beasts
and to zip to higher vantage points only
to descend onto a rider and deliver a
hard kick these are the moments that
represent Arkham Knight at its very best
hand-to-hand combat continues to set the
bar high and is so hard-hitting it's
difficult to believe the near constant
reminders that Batman isn't killing
anyone but melee battles feel so so good
giving Batman's fists as much raw power
as any hammer or club stealth combat
sequences which offer astounding
flexibility in how you approach enemies
are as good as ever
slinking through vents taking down a
goon and zipping away is as rewarding as
it is to sabotage your armed foes with
your disruptor rifle causing their
weapons to malfunctions and leave their
owners open to attack smart level design
and a large array of gadgets a remote
electrical charge a hacking device and
so forth keep each stealth room as
interesting as the last Arkham Knights
most memorable sections deviate from the
norm and vary the pace
Batman pieces together the past by
investigating crime scenes and examines
dead bodies for clues to their
identities the resulting puzzles are
clever and the related tasks such as
rewinding and fast-forwarding security
footage make you feel like an active
participant in a real analysis the game
constantly digresses asking you to team
up with comrades like Nightwing and
Robin to deliver cooperative beat downs
and to perform all number of secondary
missions which incorporate villains like
penguin two-face and Firefly Arkham
Knight is loaded with villains actually
including the one that gives the game
its name Arkham Knight himself his
identity is meant to be the game's
greatest mystery but conspicuous
foreshadowing and a reliance on age-old
superhero cliches make every supposed
surprise easy to guess hours before it's
actually sprung on there are some 10
story beats and moving events but your
two primary goals to stop scarecrows
evil Thaksin plot and to confront and
unmask the arkham knight are way too
predictable to be compelling and because
the game loads up on repetitive combat
encounters towards the story's end both
in and out of the Batmobile there's an
air of tedium surrounding what
would be the plots greatest reveals
there's no questioning Batman Arkham
Knights attention to detail enemies
remark upon how many fallen comrades
they've countered thus far
Batman's rifts through Gotham like a hot
knife glides through butter
and exhibits the exact right amount of
stickiness as he approaches surfaces but
it's worth noting that what Arkham
Knight does well is what Arkham City
also did well and that game nailed the
particulars better than does arcanite
nevertheless this is an entertaining
game that makes up for its lack of
impact by refining the fundamentals it's
over here Oh goodbye
you